こんにちわ
はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん・・・
折れないシャーペン
デルガード、ご存知でしょうか？
シャーペンマニアである僕は紹介したと思うんですけども
ペン先のここが丈夫でですね、
折れないというような意味でデルガード
上や斜めから強く押しても
デルガードシステムにより芯をしっかり
ガードしてくれるというシャープペン
ここが全然折れにくいんです
つまり筆圧の強い人とかが書くときにやると
芯がしっかり硬いので、
シャー芯が折れることが
ないという仕組みになっております
僕も結構筆圧が強いので
デルガードすごい役立ちます
今回でねちょっと何かのご縁が
あってかはわかりませんが
たぶんデルガードを作っている会社のゼブラさんから
とある箱が届きました
こちらです。あぁやべ
開いてるのばれちゃった
とりあえずこれが届きました
ちょっと開けていきましょう
何？
封筒ですね
おぉ!
ゼブラさんから、手紙が届きました
”緊急依頼”
"はじめしゃちょー　様"
"拝啓"
"ゼブラのデルガードは、「折れないシャープNo.1」を目指しています"
"ここに、デルガードとサイコロをお送りいたします"
"サイコロを振って、出た本数を使って是非"
"折れない"
"を実証してください"
"今回は、5組のYouTuber様にお送りしています"
"皆様の楽しい動画を期待しています"
"敬具"
"ゼブラ株式会社"
なるほどなるほど
やります
シャーペンは好きなので
こういうのはしっかりやっておいた方が
今後のためになる!
はい、というわけでサイコロがこちらになります
5本,1本,100本,50本といろいろあるのですけども
あっ、ごひゃっ
さて、振ってみるか
サイコロを振って出た本数のデルガードで
デルガードが折れないということを証明すれば
まぁ、ミッションクリアというわけなんですね
ちょろいぜ
この天才はじめ様にかかれば
そんなの余裕さ
では行きましょう
出た目の本数使っていきますからね
ほっ
いいよーいいよーいいんじゃない?
さあ止まります
うわっうわっうわっうわっうわっうわっうわっうわっうわっうわっうわっうわっうわっー
はい!
500本です
んーーーーー
動画的にはおいしい
はい、というわけで500本のデルガードを使って
これが折れないということを証明していきましょう
ホントに500本はいって…
うわぁ絶対入ってる
ゼブラさんマジすか
うーーわ
すごいぞ
これ、うれしいわ
いや、マニアとしては非常に嬉しいのですけども
すげぇな
はい、というわけでゼブラさんからデルガード500本いただきました
パッと見アスパラガスだな
分かりました
このデルガード500本使って僕が…
デルガードが折れないということを証明して見せましょう
今から
デルガード500本使って
橋を作ります
その、橋を作るんですけども
その橋のこのブリッジ部分が
しっかりデルガードの筒で
しっかりされてて
僕が渡っても折れなかったら
もう、デルガードは最強です
人が乗っても折れないってことは、字を書いて折れることはないですから
それでちょっと証明してみせましょう
では行こう
とりあえずこの机2つ使います
ほら、今机の下からゼブラさんのボールペンが出てきました
ゼブラ愛用者です
OK
こんな感じで
この間に橋を作ります
で、まぁ要するに
この芯の部分でこの橋を支えればいいので
こういう感じね
ここさえしっかりできればいいと思っているので
この間は別にデルガードじゃなくてもいいと思ってるので
鉄パイプを使います
この鉄パイプ実はデルガードとほぼサイズがぴったりで
こういう感じで先だけが出るようになります
これを両サイドに入れて
いい感じに、こんな感じじゃないですか?
ほら、ちゃんとデルガードの芯でもっています
ここですごいじゃん、もう
え、もうこれ来たじゃん
完全に来たじゃん
こういう感じで
デルガードの筒の先端を使ってとりあえず、橋の
もととなる部分を作っていきましょう
はい、というわけで橋のベースは完成しました
これ全部デルガードの筒の部分だけで支えております
もうこの時点で結構感動しているのですけども
問題はここからです
これをしっかりとした橋にしていくために
僕が歩くところを残りのデルガードで作っていきましょう
うわーー
うわーーーーーー
完成しましたーーー
うわーはっはぁー
大変だったよーーー
はい、というわけで完成しました
いや、マジで大変だったからね
はい、ここからなんですけど
このデルガード
芯が出ていない状態で3ノック以上すると
折れてしまう可能性があるらしいです
なので、シャー芯を出すときは2ノックぐらいかな
そしたら、非常に丈夫で折れないらしいです
ということで
ホントにデルガードから出るシャー芯は
折れないのかという検証をしたいので
こっち側だけはシャー芯で橋を支えてもらいます
こっちはそのままこの筒の方で支えてもらいます
こっちサイドはシャー芯ですので
こっちサイドがいかに
僕が乗ったときに折れるか折れないかが
ポイントになります
では、芯を出していきましょう
はい、というわけで完成しました
シャーペン500本
デルガードで作った橋
デルガードの芯は本当に折れないのかどうか
橋の上を渡って、検証してみようと思います
行きます
もうヤラセなしですよ
一発勝負です
もう企業関係とかなし
もう本当に俺はデルガードを信じるしかないです
では
デルガードは本当に折れないのか検証して行こうと思います
行きます
Three , Two , One (3,2,1)
はい、折れました
まぁまぁ、こればかりは仕方ないです
橋を作ってしまうと
デルガードの芯が折れるってか、僕の作り方の問題だったかもしれませんね
ということでデルガード
多分僕とか筆圧の強い方にはとても強い武器になると思います
もうガリガリ書けますからね
正しい使い方をすればまず折れることはないので
是非よかったら使ってみてください
今回ですね僕以外のYouTuberもデルガードの動画をあげております
私はじめしゃちょーそしてフィッシャーズ、水溜りボンド、アバンティーズ、トミックさん、そしてボンボンTVも動画をあげております
よかったらそちらもチェックしてみてください
あの…
正しく使おうね
じゃあな